long time a president of the
Philadelphia Eagles and CEO of the
Cleveland Browns man who's been around
the NFL front offices for many a moon
he's Joe banner back here on the right
guys and show how are you Joe I always
appreciate our conversations you bring
some you bring some insight Joe and the
first thing I just wanted to throw it
out there is is certainly you do
obviously have an experience of an
executive how should people take
comments from you about all this heads
up just coming in about your take from
this point of view of being a fair and
balanced in that regard Joe let's know
that out also you know is kind of I
guess a federal resume I was obviously
in management all my time of the NFL and
I in fact was on the team of people that
negotiated the 2011 deal on behalf of
the players which I say I mean on behalf
of the owners right which I think most
people was where degree was you know a
good deal from the owner perspective but
my heart and my my life is historically
much more sympathetic to the for the
worker than management that's true so
I'm not pretending total objectivity but
I think a fairly dispassionate balanced
view okay so then let's get right into
it then your take on this agreement
again it's an excellent column I should
suggest everybody seek it out on USA
Today your your thoughts on this
collective bargain agreement that is now
being voted on through Saturday would be
what I have no pretension that it's a
great deal for the players and I am
totally understanding any player that
feels like even 17 games as a
non-starter so there are no vote I think
those are both completely reasonable
positions I hear them from people I
don't have any argument with it on the
other hand if you've if you're okay with
17 games as long as you get enough in
return I've made the case that the play
is really good quite a bit the owners
really went in with a little about this
but a single issue that they wanted to
make sure they got which is not uncommon
in negotiations the other side can
choose the same for example the union
could have said you know we're not we
don't care about anything other than
percentage we get in the revenues
because we just want every player's
salary
or they could have said there's a lot of
issues that we're not satisfied we're a
town where we want to make progress at
least incremental progress on a very
wide list and they chose the latter and
I would argue that if you look at it in
detail they actually did extremely well
in having that incremental progress made
on a wide range of issues major progress
for young players major for minimum
salary players huge result in the
response of veteran players retired
players that haven't been satisfied
while still getting a solid deal for
veterans although they are the weak weak
in the deal but they're still well taken
care of
what do you mean the wink wink in the
deal what do you mean by that no I just
mean that that there's a weak link all
the weekend another retired players the
younger players did better than the
veterans but my belief is all three of
them did reasonably well okay so what do
you make of the news that the collective
bargaining agreement of a vote has been
pushed 48 hours for a deadline where
does that come from well I do think in
you know I have the benefit of having
talked to players and having talked to a
number of agents who are talking to
their players the players don't have the
information and the extent of the
information a chance to ask questions
even challenge things that they need to
feel confident in their vote so right
now there's too much influence coming
from the outside and the Twitterverse
and a couple of highly vocal players and
a couple of people that are you know for
or against the deal they really need to
focus on you know what did we give up
and what did we get and if we don't take
this deal what are the chances we do
better and then I would ask the question
if we don't take it now what are the
chances we do worse and you know I do
think that it was good to see that
extended and I saw there was a question
where somebody asks do you need to put
out a document comparing the 2011 Delta
this deal so they could actually see
where they made progress and where they
didn't so I think it's a good thing I
think if the players really understand
the deal I think the HOH yes and I don't
any disparaging way their their busy
lives and some were traveling in the
offseason so on and so forth so you know
taking a foreigner page document and
expected somebody to understand that
does have an expertise in this area is
really not realistic well Erik
did that and he sent it off to his
lawyers and you saw the answer today
to the he asked his lawyers including
Mark Geragos whose what was quite well
known and their response to it was hell
no and then you you you kind of chimed
in on this what about that cuz I'm sure
Eric Reid's response is gonna go in a
lot of places and people should I guess
seek that out yeah I mean whether my
response is that if if Eric's intent was
to get an outside voice to look at the
deal and give him an honest opinion
where what are the good parts what are
the bad parts and overall what's your
recommendation I just think you have to
go to somebody who's understanding the
business of football and the history of
these negotiations and can give you that
answer from a very objective seat you
know a lawyer looks at things from a
very literal and legal perspective and
you know may not have any context of you
know what's possible
you know if we're trying to make
progress here on a large number of
issues that was the decision of the
players I can tell you beyond any shadow
of a doubt I saw the write-up of the
initial proposal that the Union gave to
the league and clearly reflected that
they weren't focused on a small number
of issues as the league was they were
focused on a very large number of issues
well if you go into negotiation like
this with a long list that you're gonna
realize you're not going to get the full
degree of what you want on any issue but
maybe you can get a lot of what you want
but a whole bunch of issues and that's
what they did so I just don't think it's
the right source if his goal was to
really be better informed I'm not sure
it's the best place to go to get that
answer former Brown CEO and former
Eagles President Joe banner here on the
Rich Eisen show on the day that his take
on the CBA and what the players should
think about it dropped in USA Today he's
here on the Rich Eisen show and then
this past weekend Joe there was a report
in ESPN that some owners are hoping the
players vote no because they wanted an
18th game and they would love to
renegotiate to get that 18th game and
many thought that that was a signal of
smoke from the NFL to tell the players
to take this deal in a threatening
manner saying if you don't like this the
way it is right now guess what
wait to see the next one if you vote no
on this one is that something that you
think owners knowing in the front
offices and the way it works would would
actually leak through o sources well I
think the notion that the owners would
leak something that applied pressure to
the players to do the deal now versus
later and vote YES on this deal it's
totally plausible as I think is the
union also people are doing that and
most people in these kind of
negotiations even if it's just for
single-player are but I've been pretty
dismissive up the report that the owners
want 18 games you know i sat in on some
of the discussions about the challenges
of putting pushing the season earlier
and starting on Labor Day and the
history of how ineffective that was from
a ratings perspective I've seen on the
meetings with the reports of the
regular-season ratings when you start to
get into January and they drop off
dramatically to think that the owners
are really thinking they're better off
with 18 years I don't think there's
significant additional TV money for an
18th game because of where it falls and
therefore having said in on those
discussions I think it's plausible that
the owners would leak something that
would make the players think that it was
better to take the deal now than later
but the specifics of the 18 game part I
just it's not credible to me from what I
know well then how plausible is it that
if the players don't take this deal
there's no shot that they actually get
one that's more improved from under the
set my answer is a lot of percent now
I'm saying it this way if you factor in
what they lose this year which will be
some TV money because negotiating these
deals is going to happen this year and
there'll be worse if there's no labor
peace or at least no surety of labor
peace and the players lose some of that
money as do the owners so it's bad for
both sides they're going to lose money
and benefits that was going to be
increased this year as well as 100
million dollars that was going to be
added you know straight into the cap and
potentially and probably lose the extra
money which was quite a bit from the
added playoff game that's in the
proposal is going to start this year so
they have to do better than this deal by
that much just to break even and I've
sat in the meeting people understand
there's a group
the onus was called the cec it's really
the owners that drive the decisions and
they're the ones that determine when the
deal is good enough to bring to the full
membership with their recommendation
I've sat in the meetings as of the
negotiations were happening at 2011 with
those eight owners and I'm just going to
tell you my opinion is that if they play
the players wait to lecture to do the
deal it will not be as good as what they
have on the table at this moment so how
much are the TV deals driving all this
Joe obviously very important but you
know I make the point that some people
seem to skip over it's equally important
to both sides you know the players in
the new deal would have a cap literally
48 percent or practically at least forty
eight point five maybe even forty eight
point eight depending upon the TV deals
the owners get the other fifty one odd
percent but the owners have to pay
expenses out of the fifty one percent so
they actually net less money than the
players do on that type of a transaction
so that's why I say both sides should
realize they're having labor peace and
negotiating a long term TV deal with
their partners with a partner having
surety is a benefit to both sides and
not a leverage point for either side
somehow the discussion is led to all the
players have leverage because the owners
need the TV deal by now now neither side
is leverage on this issue they both
incentivize to maximize this deal it's
the biggest thing that drives the cap
it's the biggest thing that drives the
economics both for the owners and the
players so last one for you on this
subject before I let you go Joe banner
why should fans care about this I
totally would understand why some might
be listening to any of these
conversations or reading about it on
Twitter saying just you know just get it
done
why should fans care about what we have
just discussed and what's coming over
the next four five days
Joe well I can only really give you two
reasons and I wouldn't tell them they
should kill a whole lot because it's not
the front side of the business from a
fan perspective but the two reasons are
one if there isn't a deal done now
there's a real chance of not having
football in 2021 for at least a part of
the season and there's not even a way
you could rule out not all of the
seasons so I assume fans that really
love the game would be upset by that
as you look at your particular team and
your richest rooting for your your fan
interest if you have a team that you
know the Panthers the Jaguars the Eagles
that have been running you know tight to
the cap you'd love to see a deal that
gave the team certainty the cap is going
to go up significantly they could fold
with their plans and not worry about
anything cut players would be afraid to
resign players there's anything if your
team that has a ton of cap room you
maybe just find not seeing the deal done
because it's going to give your team at
least a short-term advantage of having
extra money that other teams won't have
because they don't have certainty about
what the caps going to be going forward
so those are the only two reasons I
could think and I would tell them that
you know keep an eye on it but you know
free agency is a few days away and
that's that's really what's going to
matter in the immediate future okay and
then in terms of free agency that's just
a few days away you got any two cents
and what do you think Brady's gonna do
any idea what do you think - between San
Francisco in New England and I know
nothing so I'm just giving you contra
you know where does it make sense it's
got to be a place he really wants to
play if he's going to leave and I
believe it's going to be a place that
has a chance to win the Super Bowl I
also think he probably is watch Kyle
Shanahan for years and you know probably
the only place you could look where he
isn't it has a chance to really have a
dynamic offense that could be really
creative and take advantage of what it
brings to the table and then you know if
I just he's got a close relationship
with the crafts and they're very
persuasive when you get in these
situations at the last minute and you
know there is something to be said for
finishing your whole career with one
team not that many people have have done
it so that's my guest there other teams
that could certainly happen it wouldn't
shock me but those are my top two and
what about the idea that the Cowboys
have finally put a 33 million dollar a
year deal on the table for dak and how
do you think that plays on yeah you know
I was on your show a number of months
ago and said I ought to be able to get
done before the beginning of his run you
could take my ads with a grain of salt I
mean I think the issue there has always
been structure versus dollars I think
they've been in this ballpark for a
while but you know here's the leverage
to get quite a sizable guarantee and a
guarantee at signing not a guarantee
that kicks in down the road right is the
leverage to get a shorter deal the
Cowboys don't usually do either of those
things so I suspect that's where the
bottle
and then I would be remiss if I did not
ask a man who has been around was around
the Philadelphia Eagles from 94 to 2012
what you thought when you saw Andy Reid
lifts the Lombardi Trophy Joe I was a
phenomenal moment I mean I can't imagine
anybody that knows him it worked with
him and didn't have tears in their eyes
and a tiny piece of the relief that he
must have felt in something he'd pursued
so long been so close to deserved and
there it was finally standing I think
you could just see that the stress just
leave his body as a clock ran out on
that game and I've had the joy of
interacting with him since then and he
is just ecstatic his players are
ecstatic and more for him than
themselves it's just a great great
moment but how about for you personally
just to just to obviously I know you
feel that firfer Andy but there's a lot
of a structure that he's dealing with
right there that came from when you were
at the top of the flowchart Joe no
listen I greatly appreciate you saying
that I mean listen we hired Andy when he
had never been a coordinator and frankly
took a tremendous amount of heat so it
healthier for the higher so his success
is something that we take great amount
of joy in and he brought with him has a
lot of the coaches the general manager a
number of the scouts role now
Philadelphia people so there's
definitely some satisfaction on that so
I would rather have still been there and
either a couple years ago Philadelphia
this time in Kansas City hold it myself
but this was the next best thing for me
hey man that's it's it's really great
and you just broke news that you took
heat for something while you did
something in Philadelphia that's news
Joe we're gonna go right we're gonna go
wrong with that one you're in the Rich
Eisen show yeah you got it and again
it's just uh it's just a wild few days I
mean that the CBA is up and then the
television contracts await in the in
between appears to be a free agency
period headlined by a six-time Super
Bowl champion quarterback at the age of
close to 43 can make a ripple effect
from where everybody else goes and that
also includes the draft it's really
amazing when you think about and this is
the offseason right I mean Joe thanks
for the time appreciate it it can all
follow Joe on Twitter at Jill banner
third
teen and check out his column in today's
USA Today thanks for the call Joe thanks
Joe banner here on the rich others